[Music]
in government power news Oh submitted by
it what's for dinner oh my god that's
the question of the century not
Shinsengumi you look like it so much
baby is so damn cute the [ __ ] picture
with the Chinese outfit I almost passed
out people right I just died and I'm
writing for my the past life or whatever
China is now banning references to hip
hop culture and any actors with tattoos
from all media what Chris Brown holy SH
everyone everyone that's good yeah why
cuz Chyna's leg I don't want you to beat
a bad boy to be one of the kids is gonna
do cuz I got you Dance Studios and
dancing hip-hop and stuff all day you
got like three Studios over there
oh [ __ ] really yeah you gotta start
dancing some funny thing is underground
China's just making them more popular by
doing that because sex yeah yeah cuz
that's that whole genre they make a
living off of being against the grain
and I'm a bad boy you know so now they
just officialize that [ __ ] it's
not illegal but if kids are listening to
it now it feels like whoo yeah so the
country's top media regulator called
the State Administration of press
publication radio film and television of
the People's Republic of China
s appr F T for the communist now they
are specifically requiring that program
should not feature actors with tattoos
or depict hip-hop culture a subculture
which is non non mainstream culture and
dispirited dispirited culture that so
they're like we want we want our
performers to wear peacock outfits and
look like circus freaks these are the
rules so number one absolutely do not
use actors whose heart and morality are
not aligned with the party and whose
morality is not Noble
Giada every two absolutely do not use
actors who are tasteless vulgar and
obscene number three absolutely do not
use actors whose ideological level is
low and have no class
and last one absolutely do not use
actors with stains scandals and
problematic moral integrity well there
goes all objective is [ __ ] yeah it's
gonna be hard to enforce this yeah who
regulates that [ __ ] so what they want
like prim and proper you know what's
funny is they want so bad to represent
like that that you know they're they're
like really classy but they're not
classy yeah yeah media to know people
that [ __ ] on the floors in public oops
everybody okay that's good morality okay
but Eliza before they worry about some
guys with some tattoos maybe they should
worry about their own citizens traveling
to other countries and making the rest
of Asia look bad should we worry about
the public [ __ ] oh no no no no no no
okay that's okay everybody need a goal
from time to time to no but the guy with
a tattoo maybe they figure if we don't
acknowledge it and we won't
that's so funny they see like a like a
like a Chinese pop star adopting a
little bit of like hip-hop and his stuff
they're like oh my god is that the rap
hell no man
you know I do miss the days back in the
day a little bit when tattoos were
affiliated with gangs
mhm cuz I [ __ ] was tight now everybody
got tattoos yeah you like tattoos lost
its edge yeah it's just like an
accessory now I missed the edge of
tattoos you know it's almost like
outdated if you think tattoos equals oh
my yeah this doesn't have it anymore
now it's just like I came up with a
temporary tattoo like one of those like
John on once in Hawaii when I was a kid
and my grandmother started crying
she thought it was real okay
she wasn't real this she look at me
she's like she's like she's freaked
actually she's gonna go up to me so bad
I'm like why did you think about your
modeling then what's that grandmother
anymore but if she were to see my
tattoos I think she'd probably freak out
I think it was because like she was um
disappointed that my grandfather got
over my mind my dad got tattoos her son
got - oh she's she saw it as a gateway
drug yeah so get the tattoo did you join
a gang yeah so I think like if she knew
she probably doesn't know that I model
now but if she if I were to talk to her
she's like you're a model and you have
pappu are you seeing your pictures I
don't know I haven't spoken to her since
for like 14 years oh man my uncle - he
started panicking cuz he was like oh you
want a tattoo oh you want to join the
Japanese mob and then he started getting
some like yeah who's the picture no he
got some DVDs that basically they were
like these like how these uh Yakuza
members became pastors and stuff and it
was like this really inspirational story
and I was watching and he goes see this
is the reason why you don't want to join
a gang and I'm like what did you think
getting a tattoo equals me wanting to
join a game like how did they go from
here to there you want to cut off your
fingers is that what you want to you
have any all aboard it is you taped your
thumb to your hand no I'll try grabbing
things
driver go hardnesses damn dude I was
like damn joke the god dude what if I
wanted like an eagle or something I
wonder how they view Eminem like did
they see him as a hip-hop figurehead or
a white guy there's not a lot of Asian
countries it's like why it's like we all
strive to be white there are the classy
people of the world so I wonder if they
view Eminem as hip-hop then ban him from
all TV or hip-hop specially because he
has tattoos too right but like when
you're when you're white at least like
from my parents if you're white a lot of
the why you're right if they're just
like everything blind to it to it all of
a sudden oh he mono it's okay he why
it's okay I think almost everybody I
know how to tattoo a majority I feel
like when I when I first started
modeling everything was like no tattoos
no visible tattoos nothing like that and
then now like there's so many models
with
can they can do Photoshop cos Photoshop
now and there's makeup that usually
covers it - yeah yeah that makeup - now
since the ban has been announced they've
removed a lot of rappers and like ooh so
there's little sandwich this prominent
rapper baby rainbow girls
guy-sensei you know there's that there's
the Chinese rap group that talks about
like Chinese food and all that stuff you
gonna learn Chinese no no they're pretty
dope and in they had like pretty cool
voices thank a child with them I got my
job I'm stiff and carry got a South yeah
so no rapping in Chinese they can't if
you can't rap I mean like in China
they're not gonna pick up your stuff out
there right so that means Jin doesn't
get a career and all that cuz you know
how he used to be pretty big out there
yeah Hong Kong after learn Chinese it
was what did he still blow up after you
- no no I know that he went - yeah
you're the face of [ __ ] soy belt for
a long time cute soy milk is such a cute
thing to like feature for a robbery -
yeah as a man's drink yeah this other
rapper named Al Yankee hey love the
Chairman leg I don't now chairman music
instagram named chairman male and it's
the best name of crypto kitty yeah but
they've been just removing a lot of
rappers from their official YouTube
channels and that's all like competition
shows like they're not allowed anymore
are they saying like oh we don't want
all people to turn black like what's
your thing I don't get it the people of
China they've they've been writing you
know they're angry about this band
because they're saying like how can the
government with high culture have such
childish logic someone wrote on Weibo
someone else said and her husband is 16
don't like them let's go
the Chinese opera the Muslim Mary my god
sounds like a [ __ ] out of two
violator she just trying to avoid all
the notes that are on key all the black
jeans just the black Julie son's mom was
like she did opera and ballet which
opera though Chinese opera don't ever
ever say goodbye this other comment says
s SAR p PF t is so they didn't want to
give Chinese hip-hop singers any chance
of survival we can go back to H ancient
time oh I get what they're doing I
forgot they were a communist country so
they want to preserve nationalism and
national pride and you know hip-hop is a
it's a foreign thing you know it's not I
was thinking like oh they didn't want
their citizens to be like black I think
it's just anything foreign they don't
want that to take over they want the
Chinese philosophy culture all that
stuff to be number one in China I
realize when you take this away people
are gonna want it even more yep it's
gonna backfire on them and with the
internet they're controlled it yeah
that's like mainland Chinese and help
you how we see them or how we don't like
the the tourists I just imagine that the
head of that
SARP whatever he's just talking about it
on the phone now on his bluetooth
headset while [ __ ] on the floor
apparently they're not gonna be allowing
like foreign performers either that
don't have their yeah that's a big
market dude
no more Beyonce dad they're gonna be
having like underground speakeasies for
hip hop now but what about Jumanji it
was like huge over there in the rock has
tattoos true knows that gonna be the
last movie with the rock over there this
is a huge deal that maybe it's okay for
American no other thing nobody all share
you know what China I just feel like you
have other things to worry about a lot
of other things
like way [ __ ] everything like a
pollution maybe she's falling on you out
of the sky from the buildings that you
build [ __ ] [ __ ] elite I don't know
you PR for China
I feel like China needs like a brand new
view on their country because every time
I think about traveling places and
people like what about China I say no
I'm stupid for some reason when somebody
says China I automatically think
diarrhea will you eat food I
automatically think God the first thing
I gotta bring are wet wipes all this
other [ __ ] yeah we have a lot of friends
that go to China for business and for
traveling and all that and majority of
them go [ __ ] that place every time I
think of China I just think that
somebody's gonna kill me something's
gonna fall off a building cool I just
think I'm never coming back I want to go
to China but I just want to go like a
helicopter that goes directly up and
down into the Forbidden City because I
just want to see that [ __ ] and then they
get the [ __ ] out I don't want to go on
an airport and they get [ __ ] lead
poisoning and pollution someone spit on
me and pee on me and then go see that
[ __ ] like a white tour company or white
tour company is like the only people I
know that said oh my god China was so it
was like me want white people you know
why people but a Chinese people never
say that Asian people never say yeah so
dumb and lazy Becca's awesome if I
already go with a white tour company
you'll probably have a different
experience I would the only thing I
would be able to think I was like now
it's time for some [ __ ] revenge [ __ ]
you know cuz you know whenever they pull
up in a [ __ ] tour bus here you know
what shitty now whenever like if I go
over there and I pull it in tour bus I'm
[ __ ] on everything
[Music]